[Aplausos]
boa noite pessoal
o esporte é sua melhor parte
primeiramente eu queria falar pra vocês
alguém aqui conhece alguma criança
hiperativa já vivenciou com uma já teve
contato sabe o quanto elas são agitadas
sabe o quanto é difícil de lidar certa
vou contar a história do menino pra
vocês um menino muito ativo muito
bagunceiro que gostava muito de aprontar
esse menino não tinha jeito os pais
puxavam a rédea curta mas ele era muito
bagunceiro muito mesmo
viravam as costas menina já estava
aprontando virava as costas de novo já
tinha jogado algo pela janela nem sempre
aprontando fechava os olhos um
segundinho estava lá fazendo xixi no
balcão da avó ou no guarda roupa sempre
pregando uma peça certo
os benefícios da atividade física para
crianças hiperativas né todos sabem toda
essa energia que elas têm atividade
física seria um mecanismo uma forma de
disciplinar ela é de saber pede fazer
com que ela saiba lidar com uma
coletividade trabalhar com mais crianças
né além de trabalhar a parte física dela
que é extremamente importante né
vou mostrar pra vocês um pouquinho para
um pouquinho agora fala do menino vou
falar um pouquinho que eu passo para
vocês eu sou atleta do lançamento do
disco na boca da minha prova para vocês
sou responsável
liberando um pouco de energia - essa é a
melhor marca da minha carreira 55 metros
e oito centímetros no lançamento do
disco pouquinho do arremesso do peso
agora na mira de energia melhor marca na
carreira 17 metros e 48 um pouco das
minhas medalhas eu vou contar um pouco
da minha história pra vocês votam em 30
vezes campeão estadual 20 participações
em campeonatos brasileiros e mais de
cinco campeonatos internacionais já
participei e pra falar a verdade pra
vocês aquela criança que aconteceu agora
há pouco era eu né
uma criança muito bagunceira e eu me
transformei em um atleta usei
toda essa energia que eu tinha e fui
desempenharam no esporte
aqui foi onde tudo começou o pessoal um
pouquinho antes disso né eu comecei no
esporte na escola continuava com aquela
energia toda eu procurava fazer o máximo
de atividades possíveis no sport tinha
tênis de mesa na escola estava lá tinha
handebol estava lá tinha basquete também
estava lá futsal também estava lá todas
as modalidades que tinha na cidade
eu participei né dentro da escola e fora
dela busquei escolinhas até encontrar a
minha paixão que foi o atletismo é
vivenciei a primeira primeira competição
entre escolas em 1999 onde eu tenho
guardada até hoje minha primeira medalha
de madeira e guardar dinheiro junto com
as outras e na época de 2000 2002 o
treinador da equipe me convidou para
treinar junto com eles né esse era o
nosso espaço de treinamento na época é
materiais muitos materiais defasados né
tinha muita dificuldade quanto a isso a
gente seguiu é na época meu treinador
ainda era atleta ea gente tinha muita
dificuldade com o material como já citei
antiga antes pra vocês principalmente
material ou sapatilhas né que a maioria
dos materiais eram importados ea gente
não conseguia no tamanho
na época utilizava que era do meu ex
treinador é que ele calçava 38 eu já
estava calçando 40 então de dinheiro
ficava ali espremido querendo sair para
fora
até que enfim conseguimos comprar essa
partilha pra mim mas ainda não era o
número certo
ela veio 46 não deu muito certo mas a
gente seguiu assim mesmo né competir nos
campeonatos estaduais né
disputei meu primeiro minha primeira
lecce que era até 16 anos jogos
estudantis onde eu fui quarto colocado
na prova de arremesso do peso isso com
16 anos não com 15 anos desculpa e no
ano seguinte seria meu último ano foi
quarto colocado não desanimei
mas também vou ter com aquela sensação
de que poderia ter sido melhor e voltei
a focar muito nos treinos naquele mesmo
ano eu consegui uma vaga no campeonato
brasileiro.no na cidade do rio de
janeiro
esse atleta o meu lado na época era o
recordista brasileiro adulto é um
nesta que me deu muito é me deu muita
força para que eu continuasse
ele já estava em fim de carreira mas era
recolhido da da prova no ano
vocês podem ver em que é quase o mesmo
tamanho pouco mais magro só que eu tinha
uma qualidade diferente dos outros
atletas
por mais que fosse menor que essa
dificuldade e isso dificultava muito a
arremessar o peso peso tem na época
tinha quatro quilos mas eu sabia que a
categoria adulto 17 que os 260
então ele me incentivou muito porque
tinha uma qualidade diferente de
diferencial dos outros atletas já era
muito veloz
eu era magro mas era muito rápido e isso
nos implementos menores onde ajudava
demais e eu continuei treinando e me
divertindo também porque a gente viajava
nas ligações de santa catarina
representando nosso estado
ficávamos nos hotéis muito bacanas e a
gente se divertia muito porque era tudo
adolescente de 17 anos em que testava as
camas assim brincava bagunça era tudo
alegria não era nada profissional ainda
era diversão
a meta era conseguir viajar esse evento
e começou a marcar bastante já eu vi que
o sport estava tomando outro rumo na
minha vida quando eu disputei o
campeonato dos joguinhos abertos de
santa catarina que até 18 anos na época
e eu com 16 anos foi campeão da prova
então eu vi que eu tinha um potencial e
estava começando a focar mais no lado
profissional do sport porque chegamos 17
anos eu teria que tomar uma decisão ou
ia trabalhar né pra conseguir ter uma
renda ou focavam no esporte tentaria
viver daquilo ali só que na época o meu
salário de atleta era de 150 reais por
mês
então muito difícil de se manter com
esse valor
na época eu lembro que quando receber o
primeiro salário de 150 reais eu passei
antenas em quatro vezes para poder
treinar né a gente tinha muitas
dificuldades no esporte por não ser um
esporte tão popular né
poucas pessoas já devem ter visto o
atletismo mas eu continuei firme atrás
do meu sonho
essa foto é muito bacana essa foto aqui
é estão os melhores atletas que o estado
já teve alguns mais com mais idade mais
experientes
e os mais jovens ali um dos mais jovens
da prova sou eu e o segundo da direita
para a esquerda de camisa branca
1666 era na época um dos melhores
atletas que santa catarina já teve nas
provas de arremesso
ele era recordista estadual ele era
recordista absoluto
o recorde absoluto significa o seguinte
é a melhor marca alcançada até hoje na
história
então ele fez história no esporte um
baita de um atleta representou o brasil
por vários sul-americanos
então era um cara de referência nesse
evento aí ele já tinha aposentado mas
ele entrou na prova para dar incentivo e
estar junto com o pessoal ainda
prestigiar o evento e no ano de 2006
eu consegui chegar a uma das metas que
nós tínhamos que era tentar uma medalha
nos jogos abertos em santa catarina
pra quem não sabe os jogos abertos em
santa catarina é a segunda maior
competição entre cidades do país e eu
fui o segundo colocado é uma prova que
me marcou bastante pois é um atleta mais
jovem participante é com 17 anos foi o
segundo colocado atrás apenas de um
grande amigo marcelo cmn que no ano
passado foi campeão mundial militar né e
mundial master
então é um cara que tem uma experiência
extraordinária ea vida seguiu
no ano de 2007 fiz uma pré temporada
excelente comecei o ano muito bem
treinei muito
mas tive um problema tive uma lesão que
me deixou afastado por algumas semanas
mas eu tinha um compromisso muito
importante naquele ano quero campeonato
brasileiro juvenil que valia índice para
o campeonato sulamericano caso não
participasse e não ficar entre os dois
primeiros
eu não poderia participar do sul
americano graças a deus com muito muito
trabalho muita determinação eu treinava
primeiramente com fisioterapia e sete e
meia da manhã
depois de apostar de treinar e todos os
dias a gente fazer se esse ciclo até
conseguir chegar no campeonato
brasileiro
debaixo de muita chuva o pessoal eu
acabei ganhando a prova conseguir a vaga
o campeonato sul americano pode
representar o nosso país né
ao lado de um grande amigo de são paulo
com todas as dificuldades que nós
tínhamos
da ap a nossa linha ainda era a mesma
nos materiais eram os mesmos e eu pude
estar representando o nosso país e o
sonho começou a aumentar já que eu
cheguei até aqui poderia quem sabe
conquistar a medalha o nosso país né
e deu tudo certo vamos para o sul
americano uma prova totalmente nova
representando o nosso país eu tive a
grata surpresa de ser campeão
sul-americano pessoal escutar o hino
nacional no primeiro lugar do pódio não
tem preço e isso é algo que vai marcar
minha vida inteira
e aí seguimos o sport tomou um
um outro nível na minha vida né já era
profissional eu vivia dele com muita
dificuldade mas devia dele
essa foto é muito bacana essa foto foi
um dos meus álbuns nos jogos abertos é o
fui campeão nas duas provas na prova de
arremesso do peso lançamento do disco é
no lado em terceiro colocado ali o
atleta de concórdia é darlan romani
hoje esse atleta foi campeão na foi foi
quinto colocado na última olimpíada na
olimpíada do rio de janeiro
uma trata de concórdia e tava ali
dividindo pode comigo e isso é muito
bacana
no ano de 2009 de um arremesso super
certeiro aí conheci a minha baixinha é
já a gente já se conhecia há muito tempo
já no esporte não é só que nunca tivemos
um relacionamento e é muito difícil você
ter uma relação no esporte é você ter um
parceiro porque você viaja muito você
tem outras rotinas é você acorda cedo
treinar muito e treinar muito e tem que
descansar noite né dorme cedo também é
uma vida totalmente diferente do que a
maioria das pessoas leva sair comigo até
hoje é dividimos muitos títulos muitas
emoções tristezas e tá aí minha parceira
sempre aluna que também é atleta e aqui
pessoal
alguém lembra de senhora que me
entregando a medalha e senhora aqui era
o recordista dos jogos abertos né
nesse dia que esse dia histórico se eu
esqueci de falar uma coisa para vocês
esse senhor um dia comentou o treinador
que eu nunca viraria um arremessador
pelo meu porte físico por ação
mais magro é por eu não ter as
qualidades de um arremessador que ela
ser muito forte e o tempo passou e neste
dia aqui eu bati o recorde dele que
durava 26 anos né nova 26 anos recorde
dele eu fui campeão da prova por dois
cêntimos e bate recorde dele então ele
berrava na grade lá puxa treinar o
pessoal nem eu achei não puxa não deixa
assim por dois cêntimos eu bati o
recorde dele e nada mais justo do que o
supercampeão entregar a medalha pra mim
essa foto me marcou muito
a gente é muito amigo hoje e eu mostrei
que seria possível né
continuei minha carreira continuou
treinando foto do campeonato brasileiro
indoor que disputa em são paulo
vocês podem ver né ainda liberando
energia sempre com a boca aberta de novo
essa foto aqui é do troféu brasil de
atletismo é o maior evento da américa
latina de atletismo e eu por duas vezes
foi quarto colocado foi o quarto
colocado no arremesso do peso e quarto
colocado no lançamento do disco ainda
não ver a medalha mas vai vir a foto do
campeonato dos 21º jasc onde eu fui
recolhida pela segunda vez
é bate o recorde de 52 e 37 antes era
5098 fim 5237 me tornei novamente
recordista ea vida seguiu continuei
treinando em 2008 ingressei na faculdade
é difícil lidar com um treinamento e
faculdade por ser muito desgastante
treinava em dois períodos